-It is time to play
Egg Roulette,
but I'm gonna need some help.
She's one of the judges on
"America's Got Talent:
Fantasy League,"
premiering in January on NBC.
Please welcome Heidi Klum!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Mwah!
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Higgins, would you like
to explain how this works?
-Ha ha!
Yes, James.
-Oh, there you are.
-In my hand...
-Ooh.
-...I have one dozen
Halloween eggs.
Eight of them are boiled.
Four of them are still raw.
-Oh!
-[ Cackles ]
You and Heidi will take turns
selecting one egg at a time
and smashing it
upon the top of your head.
-Uh-huh.
-You won't know which eggs
are raw and which ones
are hard-boiled.
[ Both laugh ]
But once you choose an egg --
-Can I change the rules?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I want to crack my egg
on your head.
Can you crack yours on mine?
-Ooh!
Wait.
He's checking with the judges.
-Judges? Yes!
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-I feel bad breaking an egg
in your head, though.
-I don't feel bad
breaking one on yours.
-There you go.
-No, I said I will --
will feel bad. Okay.
-'Course not. It's me.
-You're the guest.
-Well, then --
-Spider webs!
-How do you like your eggs?
-Hard-boiled, please.
-Good luck.
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My hands are already, like,
there.
-What's wrong with you?
Why would you --
Why would you just do that?
-It could've been
a hard-boiled egg.
I didn't know.
-Why would you do that?
That's not what
I wanted to happen.
-James.
-Yes.
-Oh!
-All right.
-You've got egg on your face.
-I like this game this way
much more, don't you?
[ Laughter ]
-I feel bad -- I can't
break an egg on your head.
-You can do it.
-Oh! Good luck!
-I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my gosh.
♪♪
-[ Giggles ]
-Stop -- Don't wind --
Don't wind up.
You're not throwing it at me.
Be -- calm down.
[ Laughter ]
No! No, no, no.
Not in my face.
Hair. It has to be --
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Sad tuba ]
This is the worst --
-I love this game!
-This is the worst game
I've ever --
-[ Laughing ]
I love this game!
-I want to congratulate
our winner, Heidi Klum.
What a great game.
-You're next.
We're talking to Heidi
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.